the undisputed lightweight champion of
the world
the greatest fighter in the history of
the sport one of the most polarizing
athletes in all of sports
i know he's back in your life helping
you follow your dreams
what's up i'm with my boy jed here about
to be arrested for child abuse
that's right mama's boy holy
crap but because of him how's that
you've had to suffer
suffer no they learn
[Music]
hard work
adversity that's how winners are made
things never stops and i always feel
like a failure
don't forget you're the most wonderful
loving giving brother this might be the
worst push-ups i've ever seen
oh yeah i learned it from you
thanks for including me always sport
gotcha to fight
he's got a bright future
let's end this now
fighting isn't who you are it's what you
do
you're laughing what is that
[Music]
you've been offered another fight
unfortunately it's against
me the most controversial fight in wfa
history
between cash boykins and his 18 year old
son jen
every 18 year old kid out there deserves
a good old-fashioned ass whoopin
he's been saying that exact same line to
me since i was three you got to dance
with the
devil huh pray i never end up like you
you won't
tomorrow night you died on
you